[Music]
here has been the craziest journeys that
we have ever seen this gaming no one
expected this door for good yeah you're
gonna feel bad you're gonna be feeling
really bad after that in the LPL's here
and now it's time for LPL
[Applause]
a trophy in front of the crowd it just
justifies everything in support for me I
made right
[Applause]
[Applause]
to understand how rookie went from an
aspiring singer to faker junior to the
LPL's hometown hero we need to go back
to when this prodigious mid laner first
began to solidify himself as one of the
greatest up-and-coming talents his
region had to offer see despite being
the poster boy for China's long awaited
ascension to League of Legends greatness
song rookie Yui Jin isn't actually
Chinese he wasn't born there he didn't
grow up there and only recently became
fluent in Mandarin that's because rookie
hails from the same eSports infested
chores as the likes of Flash and faker
South Korea he's picked up her enemy
that I was not accustomed - maybe I got
something what else happened with Tom
one of underneath put someone on a
global role as Tom Tom - no we're not
gonna bleep it up the crazy thing is
that in spite of all his talent rookie
never actually set out to become a
league player in fact this artsy and
expressive prodigy had another sort of
stardom in mind
[Music]
[Applause]
and then League of Legends came to Korea
Ruki was only 16 when in late 2013 he
signed with Katy Roasters fledgling
arrows roster alongside promising
up-and-comers Kakao and someday this
giggly jovial player was given a chance
to cut his teeth in league of legends
single most cutthroat region man if
you're a Katie fan like every lucky
charm you possibly have like bring it
out got your horseshoes and your rapid
feet that's right start clapping your
hands and singing happy songs like they
need all the help they can get today is
they have to go up against that guy
that's faker in case you're not aware
he's he's pretty good in the middle he's
okay and it was there in his first
season of OGN champions that rookie
managed to do something that only a
handful of players ever would kill a god
as soon as it as soon as it was their
newly lowly
Baker going all-in and rookie but rookie
has a lot of temps for him
there's rookie trying to get away the
exhaust and rookie gets the 1v1 because
Jen was able to come in with the sand
United and given that extra health and
he probably would have been able to do
it either way but just securing that
kill there banky goes down impact nearly
dead as well there's another kill for
Kakao mondieu grab someone but it
doesn't make a bit of difference
Katie arrows aren't going to - OH
SK Telecom K I can't believe it
can you say clutch following the
stunning triumph over a faker led SKT at
og and spring rookie and his kt
compatriots entered the summer season as
unexpected hopefuls
you guys all go after cutting through
najin shield in the quarters and
slapping SK t1 s and the semies arrows
found themselves facing off against
samsung blue in a grand final matchup
that went the full five Charlie taking
turrets they can and a cake on the tonic
the lead grows for the KT arrows
everybody jump someday Bob salesman
spear jumping it as well looks like an
acorn watts of action as well -
meanwhile rookie gets into the back
rides arrow heart kidding occupied by
him arrow flashes of the wall turns
around comes back into the fight it's a
lot of damage on a court he will fall
first in depth trying to fire over the
wall trying to do the damage someday
comes nekkid on da de da takedown rookie
gets the kill three four zero so far
Katie oh my gosh are they going to
perfect days they will perfect case and
I just cannot see Samsung blue coming
back after that are they going for it
are they going for the win
oh my gosh I don't know if they have
time they're going for the first Nexus
turret they're going for the second axis
then SKT arrows gonna take it right here
max this is going down all they need to
do is [ __ ] sit oh my god
I do I get
[Applause]
the problem is that after steamrolling
their way to the most coveted domestic
title in league the arrows got a little
cocky they went on to get swept by Nagin
white shield in the regional finals and
in a disastrous turn of events became
the first winner of champions summer
ever to not qualify for Worlds and that
will be about it just transitioning
right on to the Nexus turrets and
believe it or not guys the champion
summer champions Katie arrows eliminated
300 in the gauntlet and najin shield
goes on to fight for a spot at Worlds
what a surprising outcome from tonight's
matches but very very impressive play
from najin white shield still rookie
look like South Korea's next superstar
and one of the only mid laners in the
world who could stand up to faker who'd
yet to achieve his immortal status Tommy
become you the Pacer Jamie I know
anything is of the core so congressman
the tricky Kim Yuna cookie Sunday it's a
pagan socketed Oh much harder but does
tell us a lot about the problem was that
Korea had become insanely competitive
with literally dozens of world class
competitors shoved into one region
people speculated that winning champions
was probably harder than winning worlds
and rookie had already battled his way
to domestic glory
I think rookies champions win in 2014
was a huge deal for him personally
there's so much prestige associated with
that title at that time in Korea and I
think for him it was this moment to say
that he had really arrived on the League
of Legends scene and then days before
the end of worlds 2014 rookie and his
equally explosive jungler made history
they became some of the first players to
participate in one of the most massive
roster migrations ever
there was also the fact that Korea just
wasn't paying nearly as much as League
second most competitive region by 2014
China had started offering Koreans
unthinkable amounts of money to switch
regions play for Chinese orgs and signed
massive streaming contracts
tango people figure if rookie could slap
people in Korea in his first year then
imagine what he could do in a less
competitive region I think there was a
ton of optimism around rookie and really
all the Korean players that went over to
the LPL at the end of the 2014 season
there's this sense at the time right
that China's maybe a little bit weaker
than Korea I think a lot of people
expected a player like rookie to show up
in the LPL and to dominate little did
rookie know this would be the last time
for a long time that he would stand atop
the world of League who knows what would
have happened if he stayed in Korea or
if he'd returned at one point but he
didn't and that one decision changed the
course of his entire career
when 2015 kicked off rookie was
brandishing the black and white insignia
of one of the oldest eSports orgs in
China Invictus gaming the victus gaming
is one of the oldest organizations in
competitive league of Legends they're
one of the few Chinese teams that
actually predates the LPL and by 2015
they hadn't necessarily had a ton of
success in the LPL they hadn't won that
domestic title they did have a ton of
money to throw it imports so bringing in
players like rookie and Kakao it's
definitely an effort to reverse those
fortunes by the time the spring playoffs
were underway IG had pretty much
cemented themselves as a
middle-of-the-pack roster and their
occasional flashes of brilliance weren't
enough to stand up to the Chinese Korean
super team that would go on to take 2015
by storm
gee I just thrown in the towel here that
much is clear
see the ice just going down kids not
even interested in harassing them
because he has no they have no chat and
EDG have completely dominated Invictus
gaming and that was just an absolute
dismantlement of the Invictus gaming
lineup and this is the 6-0 squad that we
were talking about before and just
unable to stand up to the raw power and
just strategic but just better than this
just better after finishing the regular
season and fifth oh geez playoff hopes
were crushed
rookies semi final bout against the
dominant EDG unfolded exactly as
everyone had feared they're gonna finish
off this game and what I thought will be
a tight knit series was a complete
whitewash for Edward Gein and EDG come
back into the phone we've seen them in
the regular season taking the series in
a sweep 3-0 versus Invictus gaming and
IG a team who we praised for their
adaptation and flexibility against vici
showed up with almost nothing today 8hg
just never looked at stuff
needless to say rookie entered summer
with a bit of a chip on his shoulder
but it paid off and IG were able to
upgrade their regular season standing
from 5th to 3rd they entered the
playoffs as actual contenders and
despite losing the semi finals to xiaogu
got to exact their revenge on EDG in the
3rd place match gets onto Mako as well
pumps the ultimate dance the cop back
video yeah rookie he gets exhausted
those pong he's exhausted as well sees
whether he can get back in the fight but
rookie just cleaning up under the tardis
cacao taking no damage at all yeah sword
falls to kid pot death sorry is gonna be
taken down by the echo and Nexus hearts
now under fire Invictus gaming looking
to take down EDG claim the 3rd spot and
look to put themselves in a great place
heading towards Worlds demacia Cup split
one MSI all of it means nothing right
now because the run into the worlds
could not look worse for a TG Invictus
gaming water performance IG use that
momentum
take second in the regional finals
allowing rookie to get revenge on QG a
narrowly snag China's third and final
spot at Worlds having shown that they
were capable of beating China's best
expectations for IG were high going into
Worlds we have drawn Invictus gaming
from the LPL fnatic knows its first
opponent in Group E yes it does and it
is Invictus gaming the third seed coming
out of the Chinese LPL they qualified
via the gauntlet and it will be the
second appearance at the World
Championship for IG as an organization
then somehow someway IG utterly and
completely flopped even though they've
been placed in arguably the easiest
group rookies roster inexplicably racked
up losses against fnatic AHQ and c9 see
ty is gonna need to come up big but he's
so far away from mega gnar repeaters
here at dying almost immediately rookie
desperately goes in MC tiebacks electro
double kill all ready for incarnation
the damages tuna watch c9 completes the
eights and they complete the 200 worlds
and in the end despite a tremendous
performance in their final match of the
group stage it was too little too late
this looks so good the cage fight for
John c9 but it wasn't enough IG closeout
they all onto the Nexus Arts at Invictus
me pick up a win against cloud nine well
time to go down to history folks being
undefeated at the world championship
this year his first and only performance
here at the World Championship had a
great game for himself this felt a bit
like the int I think we wanted to see
that many people have predicted of being
at the top of the group but instead they
still finished for it for rookie his
first worlds was nothing short of a
disaster he bombed out of groups and to
add insult to injury had to watch as the
deity he was destined to overtake became
the first mid laner to hoist the
summoner's Cup twice in their career Koo
Tigers are falling SKT will be your
first ever two-time world champions
in an almost perfect run the emotion on
the team being felt you could see it on
Baker's face an almost perfect run here
for SKT warded one game but come out the
victors after their disappointing
performance at Worlds IG saw a variety
of roster shuffles including the
departure of cacao things hadn't quite
panned out as IG at planned and the hope
was that they'd still have the tools to
build a formidable roster around rookie
unfortunately they didn't for whatever
reason rookie and his teammates simply
couldn't gel waiting on void stuff on
Nidalee just kidding that's probably old
I need to win this game now at least in
teamfights oh and we're now waiting for
and it's completed
rookies just got a package right in - oh
yeah we called it the waitlist oh god I
have made a mistake 2016 was an
extremely dark time for rookie his fans
and the Invictus organization he'd gone
from winning champions and being hailed
as the next faker to bombing out of the
Worlds getting pushed around the LPL and
watching as the man he'd once called his
rival solidified himself as the greatest
player of all time
the undisputed best team in the world
the SKT rate continued
now it's important to understand that by
2017
most of the Koreans who've gone to China
in search of dollar signs began to
return to the lck the exodus hadn't
quite gone as they'd hoped not to
mention the fact that the money had
started to dry up that was really the
end of that generation of Korean players
playing for LPL teams from pawn and
death to model spirit nearly all of
Korea's prodigal sons came home but not
rookie much to the confusion of the
game's non Chinese communities rookie
decided to stick it out on Invictus C in
spite of the squad's mediocre results
rookie was still regarded as a
world-class talent
yeah yeah
where again the problem was that I G
simply couldn't win oh good back up boom
headshot
Down Goes the carry Down Goes the Ta'ala
and rookie he's on the retreat he'll
take the ace in the hole to the face I
kid what are you doing
get back over here you're going down
Meagan trying to retreat to the top side
and rookie the only member to survive
newbie have just demolished if more is
about to take the last man on the map
this is match point for newbie the
absolutely body dodgy absolute
definition newbie 3 and 0 i ug I need
funds they eliminate Invictus gaming and
by September they'd fall in one game
short of qualifying for worlds they
actually go in there looking for the
fight right now the Cataclysm is for the
Nexus he's trying to break it down
Megan's gonna try to stay gets out there
they're restive w we are falling he
looks around
[Applause]
w we have done it redemption for 2016
ladies and gentlemen still rookie
refused to leave China unlike a lot of
the Koreans he immigrated over with
rookie had made a concerted effort to
assimilate into the culture he'd even
become fluent in Mandarin something
which very few other Korean expatriates
had been able to achieve and I think the
reason my Chinese has gotten really fast
over a short period of time is I'm
really talkative so by just talking so
much I've been able to learn fast and
also I've put in a little bit of effort
by looking up new words in the
dictionary and stuff like that by 2018
it was clear that China had truly become
rookies second home so what does it mean
to you that a Korean player rookie has
come to China and the Chinese fans have
adopted you as one of their own enjoy
your song Luke watch is your annuity to
Jacqueline Sonya singsong call Google
eat the power so jj-just here the
children the single oh ha convene enjoy
it but it had also become clear that IG
we need to step it up if rookie was
going to lead them to a championship
fortunately they'd acquired a promising
up-and-comer it also picked up a
relatively unknown top laner a Korean
kid named the shy in homage to his
country's original top lane hero
big tray come out for the shuttle
surmount all to being used by both
pecked alameda locks him down but look
at this ash isis I will fight you
I am a pirate come back here oh no
finally hits watch keeps him alive is it
for a little bit with the smallest
amount of health remaining I thought he
was gonna die to that tyrant shut video
lives through it as for rookie himself
his play remains stunningly consistent
the difference is that this time he be
put at the helm of a formidable roster
and he went on to have the single best
split of his career Jackie loves gonna
focus to the front line first they were
gonna take down Amy and then watching
behind the entirety there's a snake in
that purse but Jackie loves the one
that's bouncing around big t5 pickup or
Invictus gaming and rookie once again
flashes forwards goes aggressively and
now they stage the top lane in a
structure from The Herald that they just
secured in a smite battle over the
course of the spring regular season IG
racked up 18 wins and were being touted
as one of the best teams in the world
alongside the one roster who did manage
to beat them Royal never give up but
with playoffs around the horizon tragedy
struck the shy suffered a hand injury
while cooking of all things without
their star top laner ing lost a grueling
semi-final grudge match against orangey
who's he looking for the fight taste
crunchiness Freddy and I caught in a
backlash jakela not upset there's bees
Clement pleased everywhere since I runs
laps around the Nexus but it doesn't
matter he was one by one and picked this
gaming members who fall then one step
closer and when the next to this party
Jacky love was not able to be to hear of
this thing he could not stand up to OC
orangey head to the credit finals
Luzi went on to finally get his title
but rookie had to watch from the
sidelines but what is certain is that
aren't you all lift the cup who's he
gets his first title in the LPL and he's
looking to take his first major
international as he heads the other side
that was a tipping point for rookie a
sad moment for rookie here he was the
MVP of 2018 had the best split of his
career
I thought he was this close to finally
calling himself a veteran finally
getting that championship from the LPL
table breaking to walsh because not many
people expected this come summer it was
rinse and repeat
IG went 18 and won and despite making it
to the very last round of the playoffs
fell short in a heartbreaking
best-of-five against orangy yet again
[Applause]
okay
made a rain
for your 2018 champion
still by making it into his first
domestic final since arriving in China
rookie had managed to qualify for his
first world since bombing out in 2015
back home in Korea oh my god Invictus
gaming it just feels so good for anyone
who has followed this team old this way
what a journey in at that tournament
everything finally came together the
meta the roster and Lord knows the play
and watch out for the damage rookie away
will he going for this one you get this
you might try realm walk the separate
and is going to be on top of them
there's the damage output and it won't
be too so looking for Eliza bollocks for
under three a no for rookie run for dear
life a shutdown I guess goes through and
this is why people are saying he's the
best mid laner in the world
rookie Styles on the tour of 100 thieves
after finishing second in their group to
fnatic in a close tie breaker
IG matched up against kt rolster in the
quarterfinals rookie would have to best
the very organization with which he had
made a name for himself kt rolster face
off against their former mid laner
rookie who during the korean exodus to
the LPL dedicated himself to succeeding
on this roster IG were not favorites
against kt the korean powerhouse were
being called tournament favorites
alongside orangy but somehow IG took a
decisive two-game lead they were a
couple of autoattacks away from sweeping
kt in game 3
but the korean super team eked out one
of the craziest base races in the
history of the game
[ __ ] ket goes to the base it's gonna be
a base number one right here right now
you count barely gonna be kept alive
taking so low the flame comes not able
to find him despotism killing spree it's
the shine still the base it's Katie look
at him trying to stay in and fight if
they can the shine is playing his way on
the inhibitor turret one of the Nexus
turrets they're gonna be taken back gate
be still marching excess gaze on the red
the shy hi G drop game for leaving them
with a final hurdle they needed to do
the one thing they couldn't all year win
a game 5 the team that wins two games in
a row has all the momentum
unless you're I G because they want to
games in row after being down to oranjee
in the LPL final right a month ago so
there is a mental block they're going to
have to get through but despite all
their shortcomings during the regular
season
IG prevailed when it mattered most
for now The Weavers wall goes in it's
gonna be Jackie love eating some shot
from death but spoiler to get himself
away a5z auto-attack ins floor is gone
this should be it Ming's in the back
heel and that means the fight continues
even further forward Tina baby they good
vibes to the mouth get lambda spike give
it a Victor's David chopped off they're
gonna be just fine really get on a
rookies got to change kt rolster have
fallen and Invictus gaming will do what
if it doesn't
[Applause]
they will eliminate the
Dean
[Applause]
from that point on in a meta all about
solo lanes the semi-finals felt like IGS
for the taking and honestly they were
an extreme short
representative the shy
simply put incredible but even as IG
prepared to face fnatic and world's most
historic finals to date rookie
maintained his usual sense of humility
and humor Dominic Lisa
Johnny will agree that you have to
imagine I too am watching you can show
you guys if you do a more emphatic on
you little Toronto wasn't cooked reason
go to talk to Johnny Carson aki-nee
Pennsylvania and you know
Yamaha certain words are accordingly
he'd suffered innumerable
disappointments over the years and fans
wanted to believe he would get his
moment of all the greatest to never win
it felt as if rookie deserved it the
most and after three of the most
one-sided matches imaginable he got it
reckless goes on a rampage but Ning is
still there pressuring onto the turret
with the rest of us is down away
finally King Victor's gaming for your
2018 world champions having not won a
domestic title since 2014
rookie emerged neatly from his booth as
the greatest mid laner in the world he
shook hands stepped onto the stage and
seized the thing for which he'd always
longed the summoner's Cup
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah Josie did yeah
yeah
little Athenian
[Music]
he's here - no idea but I'm right there
when it finally came time to give a
post-game interview rookie did what felt
right this beloved superstar poured his
heart out in Mandarin
Phaedra you know just I just sort of as
to say just look it offends me say no to
Darcy logical with ten italic to the
wizard will feature a veteran
and even though the battle was one
rookie understood that the war was far
from over
come spring 2019 rookie laid claim to
his first domestic title in China
something he'd waited years to achieve
[Applause]
we said there will be a new out champion
but it was one of the oldest
organizations could do it for you
finally Invictus gaming met themself a
domestic title but MSI did not go as
planned after suffering a humiliating
loss to Team Liquid in the semi-finals
IG fell into an inexplicable slump they
finished the summer regular season in a
staggering 8th before getting swept in
the first round of the playoffs
LNG are about to take down the reigning
world champions in the first round of
playoffs
this is gonna be get a clean 3-0 from
LNG eSports I just want to see the
player cameras for the players
themselves from Island be fun [ __ ] ahead
fill up Batman
that's what I like to see but they found
their form again and shot their way to
the top of the regional finals
they reentered a wide open worlds filled
as potential contenders IG made it out
of groups in second toppled Korean
powerhouse Griffin in the quarterfinals
and only upon meeting eventual champions
fun plus Phoenix in the semis did the
rookie LED roster fall short get to the
final day knockout the defending world
champions IG they were getting informed
people were starting to get very scared
whenever they saw IG on the rift but FBX
in all the games control IG they control
the aggression and get to plant their
terms but all things considered that was
okay
rookie didn't repeat but he finished
third fourth alongside his greatest
nemesis it might be hard to match fakers
number of titles though rookie spent a
lot of time losing before finally
reaching the top and it's no secret that
he isn't getting any younger
now grungy home saenko have a party the
route is also handle you go along you
know PD novel venture that's the highest
level movie the media I think Emma I
know has a sound it's our new pool party
means they'll find the other half you
share fancy yeah yeah she was a woman
yo yo yo holla this is e to the power
but if there's one thing he does have
going for him it's his consistency ask
anyone and they'll tell you rookie
didn't suddenly wake up in 2018 he'd
always be a world-class midlaner mm okay
channel hotel Tom you know geocache you
watch our show but I had an Indian that
what - tada - ooh you're told that has
she - OH - attention that's all you
should change the - who Marion KP need
an a-hole mmm say so I guess a way that
I didn't eat how I should pay attention
that but it took a long time for his
stars to finally align for him to bounce
back from one fateful decision he made
at the beginning of his career
unlike faker he didn't sit at home as
fabled Korean orgs built rosters around
him rookies path wasn't easy but he took
it nonetheless oh she said counsel
Korean offenses animal sounds -
essential metallic metal Jo
Oh mommy's human are going to put an
email curtain of another tweet the
annual g20 bar you know that humble me
oh so much soda candy you know teaching
metallic Udo here Betancourt our - Aloha
but we are going to see their their
hord's war songs what it remains to be
seen whether rookies time will come
again but if there's one thing that can
be said about the bubbly compassionate
and inspirational competitor that is
rookie it's this he's a fighter
but that is what's made rookie such an
inspiration to so many people his
stubbornness his ability to commit to
stick things out to persevere and
ultimately to prevail
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages